hi there
so this is the day before i leave japan
it's been a phenomenal visit here
the conference in fukuoka was great lots
of fabulous polyglots japanese and
from other asian countries i'm sure glad
we did the polyglot conference in asia i
think they're probably going to organize
their own polyglot conferences
it's so heartening to see so many young
people learning three four five
languages it doesn't matter if you're
japanese or chinese or
any kind of ease american ease
canadianese everybody can learn and
they're living proof of that so that's
quite exciting
i had some chats with
language related uh
video youtubers
and i hopefully will do more in the
future
and behind me
is the you can just make it out is the
marazzan bookstore
seven floors
i was in there i like to visit
bookstores i went to the language
department it's astounding how much
space
is devoted to tests it seems that
conventional language learning here has
more to do with how to pass a test than
learning the language
i'll show you some pictures snapshots
that i took inside
i think this is gonna has to change
it'll change slowly it's like learning
languages it happens slowly
but there are people who see things
differently
uh i was at a uh
call it a cram school
where they're using extensive reading as
their
main way of teaching kids english and
the results are much better than the
traditional way and if people read a lot
then they don't need to do these toeic
books and
the top 1000 2 000 3000 words the key
grammar
issues in toeic you don't need that if
you've absorbed the language through
lots of reading
and
for those of you who follow me on
instagram or
you or at least facebook you'll see the
snapshot i took of that school
i visited with there's a group of
polyglots in tokyo who call themselves
the trilinguals because you're only
allowed to join the group if you speak
more than two languages
and they have various things they do
like speaking in three or four languages
with each other and translating for each
other into different languages not their
native language so that was a lot of fun
and
generally i think that
japan is a very entrepreneurial society
we tend to think of japan as the land of
the mitsubishis and the nissans but it's
very entrepreneurial and i'm starting to
see i mean it's probably been a long
time developing but i
felt it this time young entrepreneurs in
language in the internet people who
understand that that we don't need
all of these books with essentially the
same content i looked at some of the
japanese books for learning other
languages there's more japanese in those
books than there is the target language
uh the so yeah i think things are going
to change we want to be part of that
change so with that in mind uh tomorrow
we fly back mark and i
uh to vancouver
[Music]
what
[Music]
so
[Music]
you